me pidieron que hiciera un problema
acerca de razón de cambio de escaleras
creo que es una buena idea hacer uno de
estos porque es uno de los problemas
clásicos de razón de cambio y pues forma
parte de una educación de cálculo
completa entonces de qué se trata esto
del problema de la escalera
entonces supongamos que tenemos el piso
en café lo voy a poner pues del lado
derecho lo voy a pintar algo así ok no
voy a pintar un poco más grueso
entonces el piso se ve más o menos de
este estilo vale ahora además de eso
tenemos una pared que voy a pintar con
rojo no lo mejor con amarillo va
entonces perpendicularmente tenemos una
pared ahí está
y recargada contra la pared y contra el
piso tenemos una escalera entonces
déjame pintar la escalera por aquí
tenemos una escalera que está vista del
lado verdad es una vista de perfil la
pared la escalera y el piso ok entonces
supongamos que la escalera mide 10
metros 10 metros va ok entonces
supongamos que por alguna razón la pared
y el piso están aceitados de modo tal
que no hay fricción vale o sea
normalmente la escalera estaría ahí
quietecita pero ahorita como tenemos
algo de digamos de aceite la escalera se
empieza a mover hacia la izquierda
voy a poner aquí una flecha hacia la
izquierda de que la escalera se está
moviendo y supongamos que estamos viendo
con una velocidad de 4 metros por
segundo
a esta entonces vamos a pensar un
poquito en qué está pasando este punto
sobre el piso se está moviendo hacia la
izquierda ahora eso que va a causar en
la figura pues bueno mientras la pared
esté recargada o bueno mientras la pared
no esté en el piso más bien verdad o sea
hay algo que está jalando la pared y
pues poco a poco se va a ir realizando y
deslizando por el piso a lo mejor hay
algo que él estaba jalando pero antes de
que la escalera se caiga completamente
conforme este punto lo movemos a la
izquierda el punto en la pared va
bajando mira piénsalo tantito de hecho
probablemente eso es lo que está
haciendo que la escalera se resbale que
la escalera pues se va bajando verdad
bueno en realidad puede haber muchas
razones por las cuales se desplazan pero
o sea lo que te quiero dar en la
intuición si ponemos aquí rueditas en la
escalera se empezaría a resbalar y
conforme se resbale el punto baja hasta
hasta la base del piso entonces el punto
baja baja baja y repuntó se va a la
izquierda a la izquierda hasta que la
escalera cae al piso digamos a algo de
este estilo y bueno luego tal vez se
siga moviendo
pero bueno lo único que nos interesa es
qué sucede antes de que la escalera se
caiga el piso vale entonces la pregunta
es
cuál es la razón de cambio de este punto
o sea de la altura de la escalera cuál
es su razón de cambio hacia abajo
conforme el punto de la izquierda se va
desplazando hacia la izquierda a cuatro
metros sobre segundo y pues digamos y
esta distancia no voy a poner con otro
color o sea además sabemos que esta
distancia mide pues le voy a poner 8
metros
ok de hecho sabes que déjame hacer el
dibujo a la izquierda como si estuviera
reflejado en un espejo para no usar
números negativos para no repetir toda
la figura ya nada más voy a hacer un
pequeño esbozo ahí tenemos el piso la
pared y voy a poner la escalera en otro
color está la escalera que mide 10
metros estoy aquí es el punto de abajo
que se mueve a la derecha a 4 metros por
segundo verdad ahorita hice el problema
volteado pues para que nos queden pues
cosas positivas ok entonces esto de aquí
mide 8 metros y ahí tenemos un
movimiento positivo y de ese y lo que
quiero encontrar es la razón de cambio
de este punto de la escalera o sea de la
parte superior de la escalera lo voy a
marcar con rosa y lo que queremos ver es
a qué velocidad se va desplazando hacia
abajo cómo le hacemos para pensar en
esto a esta distancia de la pared al
punto de apoyo vamos a llamarla x es
bueno llamarla x porque pues es una
distancia horizontal ya está
similarmente le vamos a llamar g
ok entonces para cualquier punto en el
tiempo cómo se relacionan x
y 10 bueno esto de aquí es un ángulo
recto entonces utilizando el teorema de
pitágoras sabemos que x al cuadrado más
llega al cuadrado es igual a es igual a
la hipotenusa al cuadrado es decir es
igual a 100 muy bien entonces esto de
aquí nos define una relación entre xy
que más precisamente y esto tiene que
ver con vídeos anteriores aquí ya
definimos allí implícitamente en
términos de x esto suena que vamos a
tener que derivar implícitamente antes
de eso qué más podemos hacer pues
estamos lidiando con razones de cambio
con respecto al tiempo esto de aquí es 4
metros por segundo aquí también es 4
metros por segundo pasando esta
anotación de derivadas sabemos cuánto
cambia x con respecto al tiempo es decir
sabemos de x dt esto es la derivada de x
con respecto a t
vale entonces qué es lo que estamos
buscando pues qué tanto cambia conforme
cambia t es decir la pregunta es cuánto
vale de g entre de t
verdad eso es lo que nos piden lo voy a
poner aquí en un cuadrito y pues justo
esto es qué tan rápido está cambiando y
en función del tiempo ya sabemos cuánto
cambia x con respecto al tiempo y a
partir de ahí queremos determinar la
razón de cambio de iu para cuando x es
igual a 8 para determinar eso vamos a
derivar a ambos lados de esta ecuación
con respecto al tiempo déjame ponerlo
aquí abajo entonces vamos a tomar la
derivada con respecto al tiempo de x al
cuadrado más ye al cuadrado y eso de ahí
es igual porque hay que derivar de ambos
lados a la derivada de 100 con respecto
al tiempo ok entonces cuánto es la
derivada de este lado pues la derivada
de x al cuadrado hay que esa regla de la
cadena es la derivada de x entonces es 2
veces x x la derivada de x con respecto
al tiempo eso de ella es la regla de la
cadena más misma idea la derivada de g
cuadrada con respecto a iu o sea 2 x la
derivada de con respecto al tiempo la
derivada
con respecto al tiempo si esto te parece
un poco confuso a lo mejor te convenga a
ver el vídeo que acabo de hacer de
derivación implícita esto te va a dar la
intuición de por qué podemos utilizar
aquí la regla de la cadena sigamos vamos
al lado derecho cuanto cambia 100 con
respecto al tiempo pues bien siempre es
constante porque la longitud de la
escalera aunque se resbale no cambia
entonces el 100 es constante de modo tal
que estamos derivando una constante y
nos queda igual a cero
vale ahora que sabemos pues sabemos x
verdad x sabemos que vale 8 metros
aquí tenemos ocho metros sabemos la
razón de cambio que es cuatro metros
sobre segundo sabemos pues pues no
directamente pero la podemos calcular
indirectamente a partir de el teorema de
pitágoras otra vez tenemos que ocho al
cuadrado más al cuadrado es igual a diez
al cuadrado porque x es ocho de modo que
64 + d al cuadrado es igual a 100 así
que llega al cuadrado es igual a 36 y
pues tenemos que es igual a más menos 6
pero como ya expositiva entonces vamos a
tomar con signo positivo entonces y es
igual a 6 ok entonces sabemos x la razón
de cambio de x con respecto al tiempo
sabemos el valor de g y lo que nos piden
es determinar dgt ya podemos despejar lo
entonces vamos a hacer esto vamos a
sustituir los valores que conocemos
cuánto vale x en el problema nos dicen
que x vale 8 entonces esto 2 x
8 hasta ahorita nada más sustituir x x
la razón de cambio de x es 38 pero cuál
es la razón de cambio de x con respecto
a t ue 64 metros por segundo ahí le
pongo 4 luego más 2 veces y ya vimos que
es igual a 6 entonces nos queda 2 por 6
2 por 6 y eso lo multiplicamos por la
razón de cambio que nos piden encontrar
por de entre de eso de ahí es igual a
cero vale vamos a despejar 2 por 8 es 16
y luego 16 por 4 es 32 64 64 más
12 de entre 20 es a ver déjame hacer un
poco de espacio creo que en general
debería de borrar un poco más verdad
para que no queden las cosas están
amontonadas y que no sea tan confuso voy
a borrar el dibujo anterior que dijimos
que no nos iba a servir y creo que ahí
ya tengo suficiente espacio ok entonces
vamos a simplificar aquí arriba
a ver entonces eso de ahí es igual a
cero de modo que restando 64 tenemos 12
de y / dt es igual a menos 64 y
dividiendo entre 12 obtenemos que el
cambio de g con respecto a t es igual a
menos 64 dividido entre 12 podemos
cancelar un 4 arriba y abajo y nos
quedaría menos 16 entre
3 verdad menos 16 tercios ok
también podríamos ponerlo como menos
cinco y un tercio o menos 5.33 entonces
lo voy a poner así el cambio de ye con
respecto a t es igual a menos 5.33 aquí
le puedes poner periódico si es metro
sobre segundo ya está ahora te puedes
preguntar por qué hay un menos ahí bueno
si tiene su sentido tiene que ver con la
velocidad con la que se mueve y por
ejemplo tomemos a equis x se mueve a la
derecha y por tanto su razón de cambio
es positiva sin embargo algo distinto
pasa con el valor de lleva bajando
conforme la escalera se va desplazando
hacia la derecha el punto de arriba de
la escalera baja y por eso tiene una
razón de cambio negativa y de ahí
aparece el menos tiene bastante sentido
si en vez de pensarlas como razones de
cambio las piezas como velocidades bueno
vamos a pensarlo un poquito más ahorita
resolvimos el problema para una cierta
distancia de x de hecho para x igual a 8
mientras x se mueve a 6 metros por
segundo ya se mueve pues un poquito más
rápido hacia abajo te invito a
experimentar para que veas qué
es decir deja que x se siga moviendo a 4
metros sobre segundo pero en vez de que
esté a 8 metros mueve la otra cosa para
saber qué va a cambiar la razón de
cambio de eje y va a depender de cómo se
vea el triángulo sale con esto
terminamos el clásico problema de la
escalera hasta la próxima